hey hey they gave me perspective my
perspective isn't clear but it gave me a
glimpse
that I was seeing the world wrong
and that the world was so much more
comfortable
than I thought it was
that the world wanted me here so much
more than I thought it did
that I had the ability to
be of service in the world more than I
thought I could
that I
that I was okay
you know I remember having a the first a
day even a moment of thought that man
I'm okay
and that's all it was it just popped on
my head I'm okay and it was real it was
a feeling
I'm okay
and to realize that you never have had
that
it's like getting hit by a missile
and blowing up
but not but not moving or but but also
nothing happening at the exact same time
it's like getting hit by a reality
missile it just hits you and goes inside
you and blows the [__] up but all the
shrapnel stays right in and all the
strapnel is good
and you're okay and the perspective is
that you see you get a glimpse like oh
man nobody taught me the math right
nobody taught me the math right
sometimes you teach you you teach
yourself your own emotional math as you
grow up
and you got your own okay this and this
and and then that and you carry that and
then this feels like that and that feels
like that and this person doesn't like
and this person hates in this and this
is how I feel and that's why and okay
and it's always going to be like that
endless [__] go I'll put on some
Eminem you know or some dirty Rihanna
you know some of that naughtiest sweet
sister Rihanna
and I'll just keep this chip on my back
like I work for Doritos
but that's not the truth
and I needed to see that it wasn't my
truth one of the reasons why we struggle
to love ourselves the ourselves that is
inside of us isn't getting out as much
and it's not being respected in the
world
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one